comme je le disais il y a Florence
mercatoqué qui nous a rejoint en plateau
et généralement c'est plutôt l'avocate
que l'on reçoit l'avocate spécialiste du
droit du travail nous recevons dans dans
cette émission La changement de décor de
personnages non pas mais de décor vous
allez enfier votre casquette d'artiste
peintre puisque nous allons parler avec
vous d'une exposition vous allez
proposer au prisme les tableaux vos
tableaux seront exposés aux prismes du 7
mars jusqu'au 25 mars vous passez du
barreau au pinceau de la robe noire aux
couleurs de la toile mais les deux
activités ce que elles peuvent avoir un
lien est-ce que en tout cas vous arrivez
à trouver un lien entre l'activité
d'avocate et celle d'artistes peintres
est-ce qu'il y a des des
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup entre les
deux univers il y a des ponts il y a des
points communs je pense que le premier
point commun entre avocate et peintre
c'est la créativité
puisque dans mon métier il faut faire
preuve de créativité de stratégie
d'écoute de combativité
et puis absorber l'histoire alors là on
l'espèce on absorbe l'histoire d'un
autre ou d'une autre on absorbe ses
émotions qui peuvent rejoindre nos
propres émotions d'ailleurs et on
s'expose comme avocat mais on s'expose
pour un autre c'est bien nous qui nous
exposons mais on s'expose en portant
l'histoire d'un autre
peintre c'est
c'est tout autre histoire mais c'est de
la créativité aussi beaucoup de
créativité et que de la créativité mais
de la créativité qui vient d'émotions
qui vient de notre histoire et pas que
de la nôtre puisqu'on est faite des
histoires aussi des gens qu'on rencontre
de des histoires qu'on partage avec
d'autres et donc il y a des liens
vraiment entre la transmission d'une
histoire mais qui est plus la nôtre que
celle que je porte quand je suis avocate
mais il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
de points communs oui donc l'exposition
s'appelle le paysage je l'avais pas
précisé donc exposition du 7 au 25 mars
au prisme à Élancourt on pourrait même
dire presque les paysages si on peut
revoir peut-être quelques-unes de vos
peinture s'afficher on va voir voilà sur
les clichés qui sont qui sont proposés
des paysages variés et souvent
reviennent la mer l'océan en quoi c'est
une source d'inspiration
la mère a la mer c'est une très grande
partie de ma vie
j'habite pas au bord de la mer là mais
j'habite en partie au bord de la mer
j'essaie de partager ma vie entre la
Normandie et la région parisienne mais
j'ai tout le temps été au bord de la mer
quand j'étais jeune et moins jeune et la
mère c'est une source d'inspiration
enfin on le voit bien au travers de très
nombreux peintres c'est une source
d'inspiration infinie je veux dire la
mer c'est l'horizon c'est l'infini c'est
une multitude de de couleurs il y a une
part d'abstraction la mer c'est de
l'abstraction comme le ciel et en même
temps c'est quelque chose de très
concret et puis c'est 1000 teinte le
bleu le bleu on le retrouve beaucoup
dans mes peintures c'est une de mes
couleurs préférées mais le bleu le bleu
de la mer ça change en fonction des
saisons ça change en fonction du soleil
ça change en fonction des nuages c'est
la lumière la mer c'est la lumière et
c'est extraordinaire à peindre la
couleur bleue est très présente
forcément avec avec le marc comment vous
travaillez comment vous viennent les
inspirations comment se passe le travail
alors c'est un peu une maturation ce que
des fois j'arrive devant mon devant ma
toile blanche et en fait ce sont les
c'est le geste et les couleurs au départ
je des fois je ne sais pas où je veux
aller je sais que j'ai envie de peindre
avec telle couleur telle couleur je sais
que j'ai envie de faire telle forme tel
aller dans tel sens ou dans tel autre et
puis après ça se construit et c'est au
fur et à mesure de la construction du
tableau par ses couleurs par la matière
parce que j'aime beaucoup peindre avec
une matière un peu épaisse en
introduisant aussi bien des coquillages
écrasés on est en mettant du charbon en
mettant du bois j'ai introduit beaucoup
de matière
et donc au fil de la création du tableau
et ben voilà je pars et puis très
souvent je me retrouve à découvrir qu'au
fur et à mesure je suis en train de
faire un paysage et je trouve que les
paysages ça a quelque chose de tellement
inspirante tellement
ça adoucit aussi même si son des
paysages un peu durs de montagne mais
c'est extrêmement apaisant et donc très
souvent je me retrouve en étant parti je
recule je me dis bah oui ça c'est je
vais aller dans telle direction voilà et
donc vous l'avez dit vous utilisez
différents matériaux différents outils
aussi avec le à côté du pinceau il y a
le couteau notamment le couteau c'est
très c'est le matériau le plus
intéressant pour travailler pour faire
de l'épaisseur puisque avec un couteau
on peut faire plus ou moins épais on
peut faire très raclée mais on peut
aussi faire de l'épaisseur importante et
donc ça c'est j'utilise beaucoup le
couteau il y a des tableaux que je fais
uniquement au pinceau et puis d'autres
que je ne fais qu'au couteau et donc
dans l'expo il y a des il y a de tout un
petit tour de table est-ce que ça vous
plaît la peinture en général le j'ai
jamais réussi à en faire mais vous êtes
vous êtes passionnés c'est ça qui est
hyper intéressant je trouve dans un
artiste quand on voit la passion
artistique mais c'est vrai que ça vide
la tête et encore plus des paysages
comme ça donc c'est sûr quand je me mets
à peindre
je vois pas le temps passer on est on
est ailleurs quoi on est dans la couleur
dans la peinture de on est embarqué
complètement et il commence à entrer
dans votre vie la peinture c'est rentré
assez tardivement dans ma vie quand
j'étais quand j'étais petite à l'école
j'étais super nul en dessin donc voilà
et puis j'ai une amie qui peignait
depuis très longtemps et qui m'a dit
mais écoute toi qui parce que j'ai
toujours été dans les musées mes parents
sont des collectionneurs enfin j'ai
toujours baigné dans dans le monde
artistique ma mère aussi était artiste
enfin donc j'ai quand même un certain
nombre de
d'éléments qui m'ont amené et elle me
dit mais écoute bien et donc je suis
venu chez elle et puis je me suis mise à
peindre elle me dit mais si vas-y et là
j'ai eu un espèce de déclic de et puis
c'est parti c'est un refuge on peut le
présenter comme ça ah non c'est pas un
refuge parce qu'un refuge c'est un peu
je me mets dans ma bulle et non c'est
c'est au contraire c'est c'est de
l'énergie c'est pour moi c'est
extrêmement plein de joie et plein
d'énergie et d'aller à la rencontre des
autres avec une exposition ça c'est
important oui c'est important parce que
d'abord j'ai l'habitude de par mon
métier de nos tempéraments d'aller vers
les autres mais là de pouvoir recevoir
les critiques je trouve ça très
important aussi qu'on me dise bah non ça
ça me plaît pas parce que si parce que
ça je trouve que c'est aussi ça fait
avancer et puis de recevoir des
compliments c'est toujours sympa quoi
7 au 25 mars c'est du côté du prisme à
Élancourt et ses expositions s'appellent
le paysage merci d'être venu en parler
dans le 7 8 merci à vous de m'avoir